[Música]
[Aplausos]
alguien me entendió
alguien pudo entenderme
esto
que acaba de pasar eso que pasan
millones de personas con discapacidad
auditiva en el mundo el no poder
entender y no poder comunicarse no poder
saber qué es lo que está pasando a su
alrededor
básicamente era un saludo buenas tardes
con todos
mi nombre es que i
n
yanina media yo estudié comunicación
social y le contaba que hace cuatro años
trabajé con una persona sorda y un
intérprete en lengua de señas peruana
hace cuatro años mi vida cambió
me llamo
kaloyán y na necesitamos a alguien que
nos apoye con las fotos y con los vídeos
para un curso de lengua de señas alguien
que estuviera comunicación sé que los
que estudian comunicación me entiendan
si alguien que tuviera tu carrera
llegó al local y la persona encargada de
este curso
me presenta dos señores uno un sordo y
el otro un intérprete en lengua de señas
ese día me dicen vamos a trabajar un
manual de lengua de señas peruanas para
presentarlo en un curso
pero nosotros tenemos que avanzar e ir
haciendo ya las cosas para este curso te
dejamos con el señor guzmán quien era el
sordo es un profesor sordo pero no te
preocupes porque él te puede leer los
labios él puede entender que se puede
leer o escribir así que normal yo está
bien
me dejan con esta persona
y yo quería avanzar señor adelante cotto
hay que avanzar
yo no sabes lengua de señas me escribe
no yo no sé lengua de señas
tú estudiaste comunicación social si yo
estudié comunicación social
y me escribe eres comunicadora
y no sabes comunicarte con población
sorda
no le contesté nada no escribí nada
antes de agarrar sus cosas seguir se me
pone entre comillas comunicadora que no
sabe comunicarse y se va
y eso comenzó a darle vueltas en la
cabeza mientras iba a mi casa
cuando llegó mi mamá me dice oye cómo te
fue con los cerditos
estos no se les llama así se le llama
sordo bueno conocer de nuevos no se dice
sordito omisos remo 26 personas con
discapacidad auditiva o sordos nada más
no sabes nada y yo tampoco sabía nada
hasta ese momento
en mi cuarto cojo mis libros
de comunicación de lengua del lenguaje
abro mi lato comienzo a leer vivir a
buscar
sobre población con discapacidad
auditiva
sobre cultura sorda
sobre lengua de señas que forma parte de
esa cultura sorda
comienzo a investigar y entregarme en
este mundo teóricamente
al día siguiente yo primera yo ya tenía
claro que era lo que quería hacer
le pido a este señor al profesor sordo
por favor enséñame lengua de señas
y le entregó este papel y era como si le
hubiera escrito que acaba de ganar la
lotería se prisionera
oyente comunicar con sordo si yo quiero
comunicarme con solo
muy bien
primero saludo lo primero que hacemos es
saludar buenas tardes bueno estar
haciendo
buena tarde buenas tardes muy bien
comenzamos a seguir aprendiendo más
avanzar al mismo tiempo con este curso y
vamos interactuando y vamos entendiendo
e ivo todo lo que había investigado
viéndola poner en práctica
mi vida fue cambiando poco a poco y
cuando ya avanzamos con este manual
llegó el día de presentarlo estamos tan
emocionados vimos cuánta gente va a
querer aprender señas cuánta gente va a
querer conocer el mundo de la
discapacidad auditiva guau
y lo comenzamos a lanzar por redes
sociales lo comenzamos a publicitar
y saben cuántas personas llegaron no
vamos a contar enseñar 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9
nueve personas
nueve personas llegaron
qué pasó
no lo entendía eso lo que pasó algo
hicimos mal
me contrataron como comunicadora no
llevé el mensaje de la población sorda a
todos qué fue lo que hice mal y ellos me
decía tranquila tranquila
yo estaba decepcionada porque esa es la
primera vez que me estaba involucrando
con ellos y estaba emocionada sin
embargo para ellos ya era algo siempre
pasa
anel importa
ya para la próxima
pero esto sirvió para juntarnos como
grupo y comenzar a buscar espacios en
donde podamos
difundir lo que es la lengua de señas
sobre la cultura sorda en diferentes
instituciones así no sean unos minutos
eso bastaba para ir entrando donde
estaban las personas para que puedan
saber acerca de la discapacidad
en una de estas reuniones fue con la
federación de personas con discapacidad
de lambayeque
en esta reunión escuché dos casos que me
tocaron
y el primero de ellos era de una niña
sorda de 8 años
esta niña sorda famosa de la manera más
brutal que se pueden imaginar
madre sorda no podía hacer nada por ella
quien le iba a entender
acaso no comenzaría hay intérpretes o
los policías al enseñar la verdad
luego justicia aparece a niños tal vez
como muchos otros y si nosotros nos
quejamos que nos cuesta a ellos el doble
el segundo caso aunque no lo terminaba
de similar fue de gerardo un hombre de
75 años quien murió por una apendicitis
este señor fue a un centro de salud
médica
no le entendieron me hicieron la
historia
le dieron una posición por el dolor es
como y se fue
gerardo murió por un diagnóstico erróneo
tal vez como muchos otros sordos y
seguirá pasando porque no hay intérprete
e incluso porque no hay profesionales
que sepan señas
en el año 2010 se aprobó la ley 29 535
que reconoce a la lengua de señas
oficialmente y en su artículo 3 destaca
del gobierno
debe difundir y enseñar
debe difundir la enseñanza de la lengua
de señas para que las instituciones
puedan acceder para que las
instituciones puedan brindar un servicio
también a estas personas con
discapacidad que forman parte de nuestra
sociedad
de esta población
y más de medio millón presenta
discapacidad auditiva y problemas para
comunicarse
y más de medio millón y no existe ni
siquiera 50 intérpretes
que estén registrados hay personas que
han aprendido la lengua de señas pero de
forma empírica
con otras personas se certifica
no hay en dónde
leí un artículo de un joven filósofo
israelita
que me tocó porque sin duda yo estudié
una ciencia social y algunos que han
estudiado ciencias sociales nos
asignamos el papel de científico social
pero que estamos haciendo como
científicos sociales para merecer esto
hemos investigado
estamos haciendo para aportar en nuestra
sociedad
y yo hace poco hace cuatro años no
conocía acerca del mundo de la
discapacidad auditiva
tuvo que pasar esto tuve que
involucrarme laboralmente y poder entrar
a este mundo de la lengua
la puerta de la inclusión esta casa es
una puerta hermosa el monte toma es el
fin para las redes sociales pero nadie
se atreve a abrirla nosotros estamos acá
las personas con discapacidad del otro
lado estamos haciendo proviene esa
puerta
más allá de la carrera que hayamos
estudiado que estamos haciendo como
seres humanos
voy a comentarles algo que me hizo un
sordo
sordos debajo del agua
y todos hablan
tu voz
no tienen voz oyentes fuera del agua
oyentes dar la mano sordos
oyentes a cara sordos para comunicarse
y les vamos a dar la mano
vamos a darle más a esta población ya
muchas otras
que sufren de discriminación porque esto
es discriminación
gualeguay de sueños es su cultura ellos
nacen con
en los otros primeros 12 meses de vida
aprendemos a hablar papá y el niño
papá pero un sordo no escucha y no
aprende a hablar así que no digan
sordomudos el sordo pero pueden aprender
a hablar claro que sí porque tiene un
cerebro al igual que el tuyo que el mío
iguales pueden pensar
helen keller con una sorda ciega
esta mujer aparte de ser sorda era ciega
sin embargo llegó en la universidad y
créanme aprendió a hablar aprendió
francés
y otros idiomas esta mujer fue tan
sorprendente que luchó por las personas
con discapacidad ella quería hacer la
voz
y ella quería ser la voz de muchos que
padecen discriminación y que no son
escuchados
espero que se lleven es
espero que no tengamos la necesidad
muchas veces de presentar un familiar
con algún tipo de discapacidad yo no
tengo ningún familiar en mi familia no
hay ninguna persona con discapacidad sin
embargo me tocó vivir esta experiencia
y hoy estoy aquí con ustedes para
comentar seda para contárselo y para
poder transmitir un poco ese sentimiento
lo que significa para mí el estar
involucrada con el mundo de la
discapacidad auditiva
muchas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]